thank you very much
good evening and welcome to this
Northwestern area planning committee
meeting on the 21st of June
my name is councilor Mark Durham I'm the
chairman of this committee members
please
please turn your phones off
and please
uh almost 10 pounds councilor Morley
into the uh charity box
have you members
well there you go she's now duly
sponsored by uh Molly skips
members we are streaming this live as uh
live as well as recording and by being
present in this meeting you're giving
your consent to be recorded during each
item please put your hand up to indicate
if you wish to speak I'll then invite
you at the appropriate time and please
note the YouTube live stream sound
recording is dependent on the correct
use of microphones therefore can I ask
that when invited to speak you remember
to turn on your microphone and turn it
off when finished please reference a
page or paragraph number when referring
to the agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible and I will add a bit please do
not repeat
points or questions that have been
already asked because we don't want the
meetings to go on until tomorrow morning
item two apologies for absence uh
do we have any apologies for absence
brilliant excellent thank you very much
indeed
um item three minutes it's recommended
that the minutes of the meeting held on
you're just going to uh
look at the minutes
and the minutes oh
apologies members
thank you very much thank you so yes it
is recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 24th of May and they
are from page seven I approved a secure
not true and accurate record those that
were here
can I have a proposal that proposed by
councilor Thompson okay thank you
councilor Morley seconded
um item four on the agenda are
Declarations of
interest do we have any Declarations of
Interest
members
no thank you very much indeed
excellent right okay so uh item five
is uh reference two three stroke zero
zero one one two eight stroke full Land
South of bouncers Wickham Hall Lane
Wickham Bishops members you'll find this
on pages 15 to 30.
um Mrs only you are taking us through
this
thank you chairman this is an
application it's made for full planning
permission for a stable building with
Associated ancillary facilities and
storage areas for hay and feed the
application follows approved the refused
application which I will discuss and
talk through in a moment
so here we have the site location plan
um so that I sites HDM red and the other
land ownership shown in blue
so the the site is on the east of
Wickham Hall Lane and just quite a bit
north of Langford Road at the moment
it's currently in use as agricultural
field there's also a local Wildlife site
known as likely wood and an ancient
Woodland here to the west and bouncers
Farm
um is up here to the north just off of
the plan
here we have the proposed block plan so
you can see the stable building and the
area hatched is the grazing land
um which is about 1.8 hectares it would
support the
um feed for the horses
so I can get my cable to mix up
and this just shows the plan submitted
with the agricultural impact assessment
the there's a small area of tree group
two here and that needs to be removed to
facilitate the excess they're um
Hawthorne trades but given the
the amount of vegetation in the area
these wouldn't offer a significant
immunity value to the area so no
concerns of raised in that respect
we have the proposed elevations with the
materials
the floor plan so there's attack and
feed room here five stables and then the
hatching area shows that there's a
mezzanine level above and which would
also provide feed storage and it could
be accessed by a forklift lifting in and
from the double doors here and then
there's also a ladder to provide access
to the area for day-to-day access for
the feed
this is some comparison plans so the top
application at the top elevation is the
front elevation of the Privacy refuse
scheme and which concerns were raised in
relation to the character and appearance
of the area and also the countryside
this was the scheme originally submitted
with the application and officers raised
concerns deal with the dominance of and
scale of the building so and also
overcome those concerns the applicant
has mended it and reduced the
um retire of the building from 5.6
meters down to five meters so the
overall reduction from the previous
review scheme is 1.6 meters
um
so here just to show you that what was
previously refused so it was a U-shaped
building
um
quite a larger footprint
and then they're there for
um elevations he had these Gable
projections that um had a quite
residential appearing window so that's
now all been emitted from this game
oops
so here we have some photos they come
from Wickham Hall Lane um just to give
you an idea of the setting of the sites
the
application size here to the building
would be set in
um
right within the north of the site
this is a place of the site access
and then some closer views of the
application site so here's an
approximate location of where the Sable
building would be
and again just
um more images taken from along Wickham
Hall Lane
so um following the Amendments the
design of The Proposal both throughout
the application and in relation to the
previously refused application is
considered the proposal now results in a
development that on balance would not
cause damageable harm to the character
and appearance of the site or the
countryside and it's also considered
that the updated information in respect
to the grazing land and feed storage
demonstrates that the long-term welfare
of the horses would be maintained
therefore offices a view that the
previous reason to refuse will have been
overcome and the application is
recommended for approval subject so the
conditions set out and sorry a terminal
probably should have also noted there
was a members update in relation to this
just with them
some public comments that have already
been addressed within the report thank
you
uh thank you very much do we have a
public speaker
uh you're the agent are you sir yeah if
you would like to can sit in the seat
there
um as you'll be aware our public
participation rules are that you have
two minutes from when you start to speak
and two minutes is two minutes not two
minutes and five seconds or one well it
can be one minute and 55 seconds but not
more than two minutes okay so thank you
please go ahead when you're ready
uh good evening chair remembers uh thank
you for the opportunity to speak I'm a
chartered Town planner and agent for
this planning application
as set out the application follows an
initial proposal of the same description
which was refused under dedicated Powers
it seeks to overcome the reason for
refuse love that application
the proposal has also been amended
further and supplementary information
provided during the application process
to address matters arising from the
office's initial assessment of The
Proposal
whilst not a planning matter I thought
it'd be useful to set up the applicant
Mrs Green's interest in the site for the
avoidance of Dell the applicant is the
mother of the owner of bouncers Farm Mrs
Cox which is contiguous with the
application site of likely field
where bouncers Farm was purchased by Mr
and Mrs Cox back in 2018 they set about
renovating the house and pursuing their
own development aspirations was a
priority this included stabling for
their own horses shortly after acquiring
bouncers Farm Mr Mrs Cox also acquired
likely field on a separate title a keen
equestrian family likely Phil provides
an opportunity for Mrs Greene and other
wider family members to Stable horses of
their own on land owned by the family
but that is self-sufficient from
bounce's Farm
this negates them having to rent from a
third party and will ensure that the
family will have somewhere to Stable
horses indefinitely
I just wanted to mention the access as
well in terms of its you know ability
for horse Boxes Etc obviously the
current lawful use of the site is
agriculture and I think you know it
should be looked at in those terms
tractors Etc would be using it
potentially in terms of its current
lawful use just in closing then the
refinement of The Proposal which has
taken place not least because of
collaborative working with officers has
resulted in them now feeling able to
recommend approval when previously they
did not I really do think the finished
product has tangibly benefited from the
to and fro during the application
process thank you very much that was
very well rehearsed
very very well done thank you very much
indeed
um now members um it's over to you and I
will excuse you if you're feeling a
sense of deja vu because we have seen
something very similar haven't we
recently but um I saw councilor Morgan
first and it is in your award
yeah thank you Mr chairman um I have to
say I'm I'm completely puzzled by this
application
um as I understand it was obviously
refused and Mr chairman you'll recall we
were in fact called to a meeting with
indeed the chairman of the council to
discuss it
um at which the decision to bring it
before this play this application or
when this committee was made and at that
time there seemed to be some comparison
with the previous application to land
north of Poplar Grove or Poplar Grove
Chase which was passed last uh planning
committee and yet there seems to be no
mention of that in the officer's paper
so I'd be interested to know what's
happened there and also I mean whilst
the officers of the recommended refusal
looking through their report there seems
to be every reason why they sorry you're
recommended approval there seems to be
moving through the report every reason
put forward as to why it should be
refused and I will ask members to
indulge with is if it just take us
through
5.1.6 where it highlights if there's no
ancillary leak between the site of this
property has been established
um
5.1.7 there has been no information
provided to just the need for the
stables in this location
uh 5.1.8
um
in the opinion of the local planning so
it's not possible to establish an
ancillary Elite with any host dwelling
and the Stables cannot therefore be
considered as a ciliary
5.1.9 obviously the applicant doesn't
know the the land at bands as Farm
although the agent has possibly helped
out on that now I know at 5.1.10 it says
the previous concerns were not raised or
even refusal as part of the previous
application well my question really is
why not
uh moving on from there 5.2.5 Wickham
Hall Lane is a narrow rural Country Lane
and a characteristics by sporadic
residential and therefore this
existing application site is a large
field and I put it to you the agent
mentioned horse box I'd be would be
interested to know our equine friends on
colleagues as to whether you would
actually get a horse box down there with
any degree of safety
um
and then going on to
5.2.6 the proposed development would
introduce a large detached building into
what is currently an undeveloped area of
land
5.2.7 I'll leave you to read that but
that's not particularly complementary
5.2.9 due to the significant separation
of distance to any residential dwelling
house it is considered this results in a
lack of visual link between Universe
would not appear to be any and certainly
in scale to any existing development
and then going on to 5.4.3
where the proposal would consider
utilizing existing access the County
Council highways and Authority has been
consulted and it says that the
additional information has not been
provided as part of this application
um and therefore in fact they're
suggesting that there should be a
two-lane or development of the roadway
to prevent two-way passing traffic and
there should be a condition on the
planning application are we suggesting
the condition we put in that they
actually widen the existing highway I
mean I don't I don't understand but
perhaps PS de resistance and perhaps to
my mind the biggest dagger in the heart
here is 5.5.11 where it suggested that
great crested newts might be present on
the sides so Mr Jim invict of all that
and the um uh comments of the parish
council I move this application to be a
refused
councilor Morgan thank you that sounded
dangerously like a proposal is that
seconded anywhere at the moment
not at the moment councilor Morgan
um councilor Miss White oh sorry
yeah thank you Mr chairman I mean
actually I know this site really well I
don't know the current owners but I knew
the previous owners and
um I I also have got an interest I don't
only ride horse I also drive them and
the previous owners used to do a lot of
things with the British driving society
and my horse box is an HGB horse box
that carries five horses with a large
living and it's 12 meters long and I've
actually used the access road
um to access their place for the driving
so obviously when we drive we take the
horses then we take the carriage and we
take everything else we put it all we've
got a winch we put on the same Lorry and
so that's not a problem and I was
actually going to say that I'm really
pleased that we've finally got a stable
block was down for approval so I support
the application there thank you
take any other member sorry I didn't say
anybody else wish to councilor Morley
and then councilor Stevens yeah it was
only the the access that was all the
actual turning in point like could I
just is there a clearer view of where
it's going to turn in or be or is there
an access already there
okay
so it'll be I would imagine a double
five Bar Key
type
to swing wide and get in
the
local hardware Authority is requesting
that the yeah
look normally even a horse watch with a
trailer the trailer usually follows the
box it's not like an antique so they
turn in quite easily okay thank you
um I I think In fairness to councilor
Morgan he did put quite a few questions
I don't know if you have
answers for all of those because I think
it's only fair that you address them
each point
the popular Grove application and that
was an application that was supported
previously by this committee for a
stable building and house donkeys it I
would say it only further supports um
this application in the sense that
um it's a stable Building without an
ancillary linked to a residential use
it's slightly different in the sense
that there was already an existing
um use on the equation donkey use on the
site if that's considered the same
um and so there was a previous use for
that stable building but in terms of the
impact of the character's appearance and
design of the building I think they're
they're similar
um in respect of what's being proposed
here
in relation to the principle of
development so the paragraphs quoted are
taken from their previous officers
reports I just thought it important to
highlight to your what the previous
considerations were as part of their
application
um
unfortunately whilst all that was set
out in the officer's report it wasn't
listed as a reason for refusal of the
application so now as part of this
application there's nothing new or any
new material considerations that have
come forward that would
now mean that it's reasonable for the
council to introduce a reason for
refusal in this respect
um
that's as much comments I can make and
I'm afraid because it wasn't the
previous case officer and Mr Lawrence
wasn't here and to be able to comment on
why that was the case but did you want
me to pause on that point well I I'm
sure councilor Morgan is going to want
to come back but I do I do follow his
thinking in that there are numerous
paragraphs
that seem
um
contrary to your final recommendation
um you know whether they were done by a
previous officer or not it's still there
and in the public domain and any
decision that may be seen as being
contrary to those could
um come into question so I don't know
um councilor Morgan if you'd like to
comment uh well thank you chair well
well yes I mean he really made my point
for me I mean I I'm just wondering what
how the decision made to uh approve this
because it was made considering all the
particular concerns that have been
raised previously
so
principal argument for for the council
to introduce the reason for refusal now
that wasn't introduced previously when
nothing's changed and it does leave us a
challenge appeal when relations costs um
and unreasonable behavior
um respect to of the design
so
a lot of the concerns previously were
over the residential appearance of the
building and also also scale so at Five
Point
um
2.11 I do discuss how the sighting of
the building hasn't changed in relation
to the previous application and but how
by reducing the scale of it
significantly as well as the depth the
actual overall prominence of the
building is reduced so that Harm's
reduced and then also by creating a more
a building that's a more rural character
and removes some of that concern in
respect to the residential appearance
and and alien form
um in the countryside
Morgan please
just checking that
covered no yeah
um
is it the highways point that was
next I believe wasn't it so the local
Highway Authority um haven't objected
the application they've just required
that the access is upgraded to
accommodate two-way vehicle movements so
not um substantial
work so the the lane itself and we're
confident that could all be secured by
way of condition and dealt with by those
means and just also make members aware
that there's an application that a
stables was approved at bouncers Farm to
the north
um as well so and that wasn't found to
have any concerns in terms of vehicle
movements for horse boxes so
if they tried and test it to some degree
um in that location
and then in terms of the ecology impacts
the application has been supported by a
preliminary ecological appraisal and our
ecological substance are content that
everything can be dealt with by a
condition and sufficient mitigation is
in place
covers it all hopefully does that
satisfy your well it probably doesn't
but does it well no it does I mean I'm
just looking at the reduction in size
actually probably makes it more into
size of potential residential which
would ever be seen for these rather nice
trees around it
um and I'm still curious about this
condition about it becoming a two-lane
Highway how does how is can the officer
advise how that is going to work
thank you chairman sorry just finding
the condition
so the condition is prior to the
occupation so to make sure that the
access is in place
um before any use and any harm can occur
the existing field access shall be
upgraded and reconstructed uh I'm sorry
I'm reading the wrong one I think
only one second sorry
yeah yeah so it's just involved in the
access So within the red line boundary
um
it would just need to be demonstrated
that the access has been upgraded in
fact it's not even a um discharge
condition so they just need to comply
with that and if they wasn't to comply
with that condition then of course they
could be subject to enforcement action
sorry so it's just the access that needs
to be opened material yes correct
right councilor Stevens you were next
and then councilor Thompson thank you
chair
um so we've got some things that have
been altered in the revised application
and those deal with issues that were
found before and we've got some things
that that haven't and can't be altered
and we're saying that because those
weren't given as reasons for refusal
last time we can't bring them in now
what would happen if we did please thank
you
it could be deemed to be unreasonable
behavior by the council and because this
isn't something that was raised as part
of the previous application by not
refusing it previously and it's deemed
that the council considered the
principle of development acceptable and
just yeah it just causes us challenge
appeal should they have become wish to
appeal
councilor Stevens did you want to so
that's a risk but not an absolute
certainty that this would happen or that
would happen is that that is just a risk
is that right
I think the situation is that it could
be Chan has had appeal if we were to
include additional reasons then the
council would be at risk of costs in any
future appeal
okay just uh to clarify the pre the
refusal was a delegated decision wasn't
it previously yes yeah thank you
councilor Thompson
Mr chairman um
I can't remember what month but it
wasn't very long ago that we had two
Staples on one night
um
Mr can't remember the officer
recommendation and one was a gangster I
think that was in
probe and it was enormous
and the committee passed that and there
was also one in
in Hall no Braxton Park Road where and I
felt it was very unfortunate that the
red line did not include grazing
sufficient grazing for the horses and my
one comment was pleased to see it here
that there is in fact
enough grazing not not that it exists
but we can actually condition that it's
accessible
so bearing in mind
bearing in mind some of the applications
that
this committee does keep passing and
whether they're delegated or not it's a
decision at the council either way
um I
find it very difficult to argue against
the officer's recommendation office
thank you uh councilor yes
just to the plane's Rogue one was
refused
but it was based on highways saying that
the road was an access wasn't suitable
but that was the only reason it was
refused
no that's useful clarification
thank you for that clarification members
any other questions we are we are
currently proposal-less
councilor white uh thank you Mr chairman
um yeah I'm happy to approach proposed
that we accept the officer's
recommendation of approval
do we have a seconder for that oh okay
um we'll take councilor Morley because
he
um so we have on the table we have a
proposal to accept the officer's
recommendation and approve this
application those in favor please
indicate
those against
two
five to two and abstention
Al
thank you very much indeed that
application is granted
okay members the uh item six
we have two three stroke double zero two
o one outline and that is lamb west of
Willow Zen Stevenson Road North
fanbridge
uh who's presenting this is this that's
Lisa Greenwood oh okay
good evening good evening Miss Greenwood
we can see it and we can see you
um
members here now we can't um
foreign
we are struggling to
from a volume point of view
China Lisa that sounds yeah can you hear
me now oh yes yes
that's much better I think you'd like to
start again thank you okay this is an
outline planning application sorry to
learn English
and now the science itself is located on
the Northwestern site Stephenson road
just outside of the defy separate
boundary of Los Banbridge
to show you where that is in relation to
the site which is just here
the application site is located at the
end of The Run of houses
and I better arrange in the linear
formation Stephenson road is
predominantly characterized by simply
attached and detached single story
Bungalows the site measures 0.5 hectares
in area and it's roughly a rectangular
in shape the site comprises of grassland
that is bound by mature Headroom
built into the north of the site is the
southeast Branch Railway line
that sound is a date people using home
to residential development scheme
this application represents a revised
scheme across an extended Site Area
following the granting of outline
planning act having permission for the
erection of two dwellings include by
this community
in the last year
as stated the site is located just
outside of the settlement boundary which
is classified for North average as a
smaller Village there is however a train
station located 250 meters
see if we can find it
250 meters to the northwest of the site
which serves the South Minster line from
Wickford to southminster there have been
several decisions through residential
development adjacent to the second round
of the language whereby the inspector
has determined that the use of these
locations are relatively sustainable
being within easy walking station
the current application is located more
closely to the station than music
and planning permission was as stated
previously granted at the site in
November
particularly as disciples found to be
sustainable
in terms of the sustainability
credentials the provision of residential
housing in this location has been found
to be acceptable in principle
with regard to the merits of the scheme
The Proposal is outlined in nature and
provided learnings the agent is
confirmed that the maximum floor area
across the development would be 950
square meters
and this could be secured via a
condition the built form of this section
of sequencing very typically comprises
of fungalizing Chalet Bungalows and a
condition would be imposed on any
consent to ensure that the proposed
dwellings would not be higher than one
story in height in order to protect the
character and appearance of the area
the development would appear as a
continuation of residential development
at Stevenson Road and would be
relatively contained by some Hedgerow
attempts of the impact of residential
immunity and noise Rapport has been
submitted with the proposal and this has
been confirmed as complying with the
relevant guidance
10.4 of the report should planning
permission be forthcoming a condition
would be imposed with regards to a
construction management plan to restrict
working hours and control any nuisances
The Proposal is also acceptable in terms
of Highways ecology flood risk and
drainage and there have been no
technical objections received the
proposed development has been found to
represent a sustainable form of
development of being keeping with the
prevailing pattern of the burden of
Father Stevenson Road
it is therefore recommended for outline
plan Commission
thank you chip thank you very much
indeed I take it we have no speakers
there's nobody here anyway anybody
online
no thank you very much indeed I've got
councilor Morgan and then councilor
white and then councilor Stevens can you
come over when you can go first I was
quite simple Mr chairman I propose that
we accept the officer's recommendation
and pass this application
well that again sounds like a proposal
is that a seconded proposal
councilor Thompson
thank you if that's it Council Miss
White
uh thank you Mr chairman well you don't
need to stand thanks well I have to say
um this is exactly what I feared would
happen and although highways don't
comment on access there is not enough
access there to allow the safe Ingress
and egress of cars and fire engines and
emergency vehicles but because it's a
private road highways don't comment and
when we talk about D1 design it also
takes in safe vehicle parking now if you
look at the street scene and the design
of the existing houses they all
um go off individually off of that road
now that ends and there's a tiny Square
which they don't own the Epic consultant
although it's in the red line boundary
they don't own it now I know we can't
turn an application down but have
obviously checked the land registry to
ensure that the red line boundary is
owned by the applicants because I've
been told quite strongly that it's not
owned by the applicants that's the first
thing
um and the next thing is it doesn't meet
the existing design it doesn't it
doesn't meet the existing layout it's
completely incongruous
because the existing design should be
met they should be coming off that one
road to come into the driveways the same
as all the other ones do and it'll
completely changing the street scene for
this peculiar development at the end of
the road
um and you know I didn't want this this
one approved the last time members
outvote me that's the way it goes when
it's democracy but it doesn't mean to
say that we have to be happy with them
um and for me that's enough for a reason
to turn it down so you've got D1 which
is design vehicle parking accessibility
Street Scene does not meet the street
scene T2 accessibility there's not
enough if you look at the other houses
they've got plenty of room for emergency
vehicles and they can park their cars
this if there's cars parked in that road
which is the access road is very close
to where the indicative layout of the
housing is if their cars apart there
which they'll have to otherwise they
won't have a front garden you won't be
getting any emergency vehicles or
anything else in or out of that design
so for me that's a safety and design
issue and I don't think we have enough
information to use terminal application
um the other thing is that since the
other application got approved we now
have a six-year housing land Supply and
which puts in a totally different
position to where we were before who
didn't have a five-year housing lens
Supply then
um under Section Five which is ecology
and particularly 5.7.4
um they don't appear to be showing any
net ecology gains um and I haven't seen
a nature Matrix which they should be
doing on this site bearing in mind it's
so close to the sea wall and it's
developing into the open Countryside and
the flat landscape so one that I wanted
to know is have they done a biodiversity
net gain and what is the gain and does
it meet the guidelines for Natural
England
um and um that's it really something I
would like to put forward a um contrary
proposal that the application be refused
so if I'll get a second of that one but
well we've we've already got one um
we'll we'll come to yours if that one
fails counselor right
um before
um let me screen will come back of
course you can apply for land if it's
not even under your ownership but they
should serve notice as far as I'm aware
they should serve notice on the land
owner because you
notice of the landowner if you're
putting an application in over
um their land I think it's a certificate
B
um so has the certificate be been served
or do we know if they own the land or
not or should we defer it and find out
I can't answer that but perhaps Miss
Greenwood good and of course it being a
private road unfortunately highways
haven't got any
um
they haven't got any responsibility and
can't comment except where it meets the
meets the highway
so uh Miss Greenwood would you like to
comment on those questions
they're a little bit more
um I mean so experience at the castle
but they have declared on the
application form
um that they have certain notice and
that there was an advertisement in the
world standard in February of this year
um with regards to the design
this is only an application this is an
outline application we aren't looking at
the design at this stage but what we
have done is play some conditions there
which can control the height of the
buildings so we're not going to
introduce two story dwellings here they
could be Bungalows
um and they're going with the layout
that
decide all available
Reserve matters matters with regards to
returning again
we're not looking at access we're simply
looking
here
with regards to the widely has a gas
supply yes we do have a high five-year
housing land Supply
however this isn't a capital development
um and Owings to sites location which is
very very new to the set of
it's regarded as a sustainable location
and this has been backed up by several
appeal decisions and also the decision
of the committee in November of last
year that this site was suspendable
because it's within walking distance of
the train station with regards to our
ecology at 5.7.44 they have submitted a
political ecology appraisal we've
undertaken um
contact assessment
and place Services ecology have also
reviewed the application and they are
very happy that they've got all of the
information that they needed easily
required that we have all of the ecology
in place before we can put a
recommendation forward they're happy to
do something we count secure the
negative biodiversity they have good
suggestions to give the appraisal um
prior condition and
also in talks with the a
ID regards to the Rams
um tariff and checking and monitoring of
that is all in process as well
so um I think we feel quite confident
that those masses have been addressed so
it appears they've tick the boxes
councilor Stevens
you're next
got the light answer oh sorry that's me
yeah yeah I'll let you come back in a
second Council
um sorry before I do come back did one
of the officers want to comment further
on on that
um no okay that's fine
um okay so I've got two sets of
questions please and the first is around
affordable housing
um so the site is very very slightly
over half a hectare so it is a major
application in National planning policy
framework which in North Sandbridge
would mean 40 affordable housing now our
ldp may not require it but National
policy will always override so I don't
understand why we're not looking for
affordable housing and our own strategic
housing department has objected to this
application because it's not intended to
deliver any affordable housing
so I'd be interested in some comments on
that and then I've got a second set of
questions thank you Mr Lawrence
and what we would do by condition if if
it's under 1 000 square meters that you
do not have to provide affordable
housing that has been changed by the
national planning policy framework in
that respect it overrides the
requirement in our local plan
so are you saying in that answer that
they don't leave they don't they have to
provide affordable we will put a
condition to ensure that no part of the
development would exceed a thousand
square meters
right councilor Stephen's second
question okay well I just think that is
something we need to look at more
closely in drafting our new ldp because
I feel like we just lose affordable
housing on a on a whim really
um okay so my other set of questions is
um all around the fact that it's a
private unmade Road and we see that
Essex highways haven't objected and as
we've already heard well they wouldn't
would they because it's not their Road
um for a private road I don't really
understand why we don't afford the same
waiting to private owners views as we
would to our six highways so I'd like to
understand that better because I'm if S6
highways said oh there's something wrong
with this road we can't sustain this
traffic going over it that we would
really really take notice of that but we
don't seem to worry so much when it's
not highways is view
um I'd like to understand who's going to
pay the existing residence to resurface
the road when the construction vehicles
damage it because they will and will
that be reserved possibly under reserved
matters or something like that I'd like
to understand who will pay the existing
residents going forward when the new
residence cars cause wear and tear on
the road because they will and will that
be conditioned
um I want to understand if the existing
stretch of road will still be just a
private road or will this development
turn it into a private Street and will
that affect residents legal rights in
some way and for residents who might be
listening now or watching this on catch
up later I would urge you to look into
this
um and finally will the new residents
automatically have the right to drive
and walk across the private owners
pieces of land usually the private
owners own the bit of road in front of
their property it might be different
here I don't know but will the new res
incidents have the automatic right to
access their own homes or can the
existing residents prevent that and
should we take any of that into account
please thank you gosh okay who's going
to take that Mr Greenland or Mr Lawrence
or
Lisa would like to start okay
[Laughter]
I mean as stated this is an outline
application we are we are only looking
at the principle of development at this
stage we are not looking at
um at anything else although highways
have commented and said they don't
object to the principle
um in that it's a sustainable location
and they can see how you know there
aren't any any houses that it couldn't
work
[Music]
most of this information will be secured
by a via condition they will have to
come in with Reserve matters
applications
um which will be assessed
with regards to new residents whether
they could drive over their own pieces
of land I would imagine that would be a
personal restricted government or or
something I don't quite see why they
would allow
new residents to be walking over their
land or why or why they would want to
but we will have a robust construction
management plan in place
um for the construction process and
vehicles entering and exiting the site
and that can include a whole array of
things so um but as I said it's
difficult to comment too much further
because this is an outline application
yes come back councilor scenes thank you
I just point out that where I was
referring to the new residents having
access over the existing residence land
what I mean is the new residents going
along that road I imagine that the road
is owned separately by each resident
along there already so if one of them
wanted to I guess they could set up a
toll booth or something or put a fence
across the road I don't know I can just
see problems where you suddenly start
building extra houses on the end of a
private road thank you
unadopted Rose aren't particularly
unusual that the fact that each resident
would have a right to use the road the
new residents would still have a right
the existing residents would not have
their rights taken away as to whether
the road will be adopted in the future
that will be a matter for the visit and
that could be very costly that's really
outside of our concern but it would not
interfere with the existing residence
rights obviously as Miss Greenwood has
said there would be a construction
management plan it would be a
requirement for vehicles that would have
to park off off the private road they
would have to park on the site so we
would be able to control that aspect
but effectively all the residents would
be responsible for the maintenance of
the road in the future
which would have to be skewed by a legal
agreement which is not our
responsibility oh God yes I've got
Council Morgan I've got cancer Miss
white again but I've got councilor
Thompson first
yeah yeah I was assuming anything that's
not actually included in the side has to
be
some other legal Arrangement that's a
lot of planning matter
yes there would be a legal agreement
um I might need some
officer help on this one chairman but I
seem to recall we've been told in the
past that
housing mix should be agreed or should
be defined at outline stage because I
seem to remember starting with ambitious
where we were told we couldn't change
that at Reserve matters and they will
came forward as
a large dwellings
um so I'm just asking can we fix the
housing mix and the numbers of bedrooms
now and
couldn't have a reason why not if we
can't thank you I think Mr Lawrence you
can answer that we could deal with that
at the reserve matter stage and I'm
aware of other applications where we
have secured that we have an outline
application in once we get the reserve
matters then we can ensure that the mix
is in accordance with the council's
local development plan
quickly
yeah okay councilor Morgan
all right yeah yes thank you chair just
just to say that
um unless the legal advisors of the
existing and the new occupiers are
completely useless which is obviously
always possible there might be uh they
will make sure that there are rights of
way both existing and you to ensure that
everyone can pass to and through across
that private road which would normally
also include a covenant to contribute
towards its maintenance
thank you and Council Miss White
thank you Mr I mean I I still don't
think my questions have been answered
about the biodiversity net gain and the
nature Matrix we still haven't had an
answer on that one because the land is
supposed to be left in a better
condition for biodiversity than it was
before the development happened and I
still haven't seen any one to that and
the other thing is yes this is outline
but I would like the officers to show me
on that indicative plan how they're
going to keep the housing in the
existing
um line with the housing that's already
in place so you meet the street scene
and how you're going to turn a refuse
Lorry around because the other houses
could turn the refuse lorries fire
engines everything else around in their
driveways and how is it going to happen
here or are we not going to allow fire
engines to go down or they're going to
have to try and reverse out around that
tricky Corner
um because from a safety from a design
point of view that doesn't work and
unless we can put in that on the outline
stage
um there is a turning Circle for large
vehicles for safety or whether we should
defer it for more information on how the
emergency and refuse vehicles are going
to enter and exit the site because as it
is that there's no way with that
indicative layer I know it's outlined
there is absolutely no way that I can
see that you're going to be able to get
the emergency vehicles in and out
okay who's going to handle that Miss
Greenwood or
Mr Lawrence I think I would just I think
so I can start Derek can Derek can
finish I think you know this is an
outline application
it's on a site that he has planning for
two dwellings
um thank you requested five we can see
that five could be accommodated
um
if these matters can't be you know
achieved that was a massive stage which
we hope that they would
um then then they would have to think
about the design again
um but this is simply a matter of the
principle of development
at this point
okay and the the ecology question
um the ecology question I mean I can
bring the report
peer Services okay
no objection this is this is very
standard uh I have to say these
responses are actually incredibly
thorough
um there is no objections to subject to
securing a proportional fraction
contribution towards the Essex case
rounds um I need to talk to them I spoke
with the agent today and I'm very happy
that that will happen
um and also the biodiversity
investigation and enhancement measures
now
the measures they have set out quite
clearly in terms of
bird boxes back boxes and different
things like that
um there is also a suggestion on a
sensitive lighting scheme if external
lighting is proposed which you could
possibly will be and they may have their
suggested conditions at the bottom
though which have been applied to the
outline kind of consent
so from the local Authority perspective
we have our our technical response
um and they have stated that we have the
information that we need to determine
the application
um and based on other applications that
have been before this committee with
exactly the same responses I think I
would feel quite comfortable that we
have the information that we need
um but in stated these are conditions if
they don't submit the correct
information to satisfy these conditions
which will be reviewed not just by a
planner but by a technical
ecologist
so
you know they will have to present that
information to us at a later stage
do you have anything to add Mr Lawrence
so no I think the the response that miss
queen was given is very thou in fact it
would add that when we do have to
implement the biodiversity net gain in
November the scheme will also be
administered by Place services so they
will have even further control so I'm
quite satisfied the information meets
the requirements I'm going to be very
lenient and let you come back just one
last week thank you well I'd like to see
a condition added I mean I don't support
this application at all
um but I would like to a condition added
that we see a full nature Matrix
um and that we have a full nature Matrix
done so that we know what their
biodiversity enhancers are and we make
that a condition of the Planning
Commission this is really close to a
triple SI ramsar site we're only
literally meters away from the river
which is triple SI this is really
sensitive and this is why I didn't
support last application why I don't
support this one because of where it is
and you can see what's going to happen
that whole lot's going to get developed
um you know that they'll keep coming
back with two at a time five at a time
so we don't get the affordable housing
um all right we can't say what's going
to happen in the future but I would like
to see a full nature Matrix in line with
natural England guidance and the nppf
is that a reasonable condition we can
impose okay
thank you councilor white counselor
Morley
yeah out of Interest although it is a
private road are are the Emergency
Services consulted and refuse collection
they're not no no just
I can't turn down there obviously you
know you have to reverse all you do have
to reverse all the way down
all my trucks okay is it something new
to ad councilor Mr Thompson
can we ask
Ed that they all consulted on this
occasion well no no because that's a
policy matter isn't it on consultation
that's not for this committee to to
change our consultation policy as
logical as it may seem
um right is that
right fair warning I'm about to call
them because we have yes
can we have a condition that there is a
turning Circle provided vehicles
I think this the outline is going to
come into that yeah it would it would be
the Quan as part of the reserve matters
we can ensure that there is adequate
provision for emergency vehicles and
also for refuse vehicles
well that's another matter for private
road it isn't private it will be
difficult to impose no problem this is
going to be the problem it is a private
road it's not adopted
not at this time not at this stage no it
wouldn't be right councilor siddle
yeah I surely wait we're now shutting
the stable door after the horse is
bolted because we've already passed uh
the two courses on this site yeah we
didn't make that condition then we can't
make that condition now so you know if
we wanted to make that condition we
should have made that condition last
year not now and unfortunately it's too
late
it's fair point
right we have a proposal on the table
councilor Morgan uh seconded by
councilor Mrs Thompson to approve in
line with officers recommendations
those in favor please show
one two three four
those against
three
abstention
so that's four three and one for the
clock four four three against one
abstention so that application is
approved
okay thank you very much let's go back
to the agenda I think
some excitement members
if I'm not much mistaken
we just
it is the longest day councilor white we
haven't got to worry about it getting
dark and getting home
um so okay um so item seven any other
items of business that the chairman of
the committee decide are urgent
I do have one
um due to a change in responsibilities
at Essex County Council I think I'm
pushing my luck retaining this chair
um so this I am proposing
uh to stand aside I have yet to advise
committee services that that is my
intention I speak to the monitoring
officer that is the procedure so I think
the what will happen is that there will
be uh call for a new chairman of the
Northwest area committee at the next
meeting
so yeah I enjoy this is probably my
favorite thing but I've got to be
realistic and just say that I you know
although this doesn't take up that much
time
I do need to be careful I'm not able to
yeah I can cope with SNR and there are
certain synergies so but this is a
different thing altogether so that that
is uh that is my item of extra business
and I say I will notify committee
services in due course
so thank you very much we're still
within half past eight
um and uh I close this meeting at
8 25
thank you very much